quarantine has been awfully hard on
ronnie now he's stuck
inside all day and he's getting older
and he's freaking out
and the only thing that he has all day
are his thoughts and we know how
dangerous that can be
so we sat him down with a phd in
clinical psychology all right so here's
the session
ronnie first is afraid his young fiance
stephanie
might abandon him for a younger guy one
day
well i think she's been with you for 13
years i don't think she's gonna leave
well see that's where another part of it
comes in
where my father the chick that he split
with
mm-hmm when he got sick the first time
was fine
she took care of him okay the second
time she split down
wow after 15 years also a younger woman
not the
age difference that stephanie and i have
but um
also probably i think it was probably
17 18 year difference okay so i can see
how that could be a worry
all of these problems stem from the fact
that ronnie has a much younger
hotter girlfriend so i mean crazy
yeah but it's hard to feel bad for a guy
who's got a hot young girlfriend yeah
she's gorgeous
yeah ronnie and stephanie once attended
a joint therapy session but it ended in
a disaster within minutes
what i wasn't comfortable with her just
by
just her hello just her just the way she
said hello
she was very like abrupt and
i was trying to bring out a point and
she
kind of like right away went to
stephanie's side took her
side on it yep and i told her to [ __ ]
off and i walked out
oh wow you were really put off oh my god
can you imagine what that therapist said
ronnie what could be so bad about a
hello uh
dude you had to be there
i wish i had been there i wish i could
have heard that hello
cause that must have been the world's
worst hello
she said hello i said go [ __ ] yourself
well it wouldn't be ronnie without an
inappropriate moment
um ronnie i just want to say thank you
for your honesty i really appreciate
that
yeah well it's you know i don't know you
made me feel comfortable
i'm glad um i don't i don't know how to
explain it
you're hot to look at that's a good
thing thank you
maybe that's maybe that could be part of
it
ronnie was her first patient ever to
flirt with her in a therapy session
wow i didn't really flirt with ours just
no no no
no no no no no compliment i just took my
[ __ ] dude she made me comfortable shut
up
right after the session the doctor gave
wolfie her analysis of ronnie this is
what we're waiting to hear right ron
that's right
yeah i know i haven't heard any of this
okay no
yes i actually think ronnie has what
might be
called like a paranoid personality
disorder or at least some features of a
paranoid personality disorder
he's pretty convinced a lot of times
that people are kind of out to get him
and so he's kind of reluctant to confide
in others because he's worried that
information he may share can be used
against him he operates
as if people are out to get him and um
out to cause him harm i like that my
security guard has paranoid anxiety
disorder
i like that you're perfect perfect
do you relate to that at all ronnie well
like yeah i grew up with somebody like
that so
yeah i i relate to it who's like that
your dad
your father your father my father was
like that he thought everyone was out to
get him
he didn't put much trust in a lot of
people right
well how do you like that ronnie uh
saying he agrees with the diagnoses
yeah i was a little more comfortable
with her than my own therapist for some
reason
it sounds like you really liked her yeah
no she was great
you